inyección de esperanza en francia en
medio del tercer confinamiento en un año
el elíseo pretende revertir la grave
situación epidemiológica del país con un
plan masivo de vacunación para ello
algunos campos de fútbol y otras
infraestructuras se han convertido en
vacuno dromos como el stade france el
estadio de la selección francesa situado
en la periferia norte de parís en el
departamento de seine saint denis una
zona al borde del colapso hospitalario
nuestro objetivo es tener aquí a 50
personas continuamente que atiendan a
los habitantes de sense and them y que
pidan cita por teléfono la previsión es
que durante al menos seis meses en el
estado de france se inoculen cien mil
dosis de vacunas contra el cob y 19 cada
semana y que abrían la vacuna aquí en el
estadio de francia y esto nos permitirá
volver a tener libertad ayer bien la
tarde por televisión que uno podía pedir
cita y logré una para hoy a las 10 de la
mañana pero más allá del estado de
france hay otros 15 mega centros de
vacunación operativos en el país
la intención del gobierno es llegar a 46
a finales de abril la estrategia masiva
de vacunación comprende la integración
de los 8 hospitales militares que hay en
francia en total el ejecutivo francés
pretende haber vacunado a 30 millones de
personas es decir a la mitad de su
población a mediados de junio fue mi
médico quien le prescribió la vacuna me
dijo que la de facer estaría disponible
a final de marzo así que esperaba
sin embargo a pesar de que francia sea
uno de los países europeos con más y más
largas restricciones para frenar la
pandemia su población es de las más
escépticas del mundo frente a las
vacunas